they yelled at us and they call us by
our character names and like the guys
were really scary and it was exhausting
physically and to this day it's the
hardest thing I've ever done school ties
I was playing like this anti-semitic
bully and it seemed like those are the
rules I was kind of getting cast as was
like bad guys all the time obviously I
knew Matt and that was fun and I got to
know you know Anthony Rapp and and Chris
O'Donnell and Randall Bankoff and
Brendan Fraser and those guys really
well and it was definitely like a sort
of thrilling moment cuz it was the first
real movie like I knew it was actually
gonna come out you know that I was gonna
be in it was a little frustrating to
have such a small role and that for it
to be so relentlessly unpleasant but
take what you can get I guess dazed and
confused oh I'm sorry ma'am I was just
squirting you're fine young son home
from school there's there are some
ruffians about a knight
oh and Mitch Carl we'll be seeing each
other again what are you shouting for
the O'Bannon character at one time that
you wrote [ __ ] you on the paddle
yourself I don't know if that was me or
if that was Rick's idea I I can't
remember but uh Rick encouraged everyone
to like write their own stuff do you
know try their own scenes like which is
kind of amazing to me that he gave us
all that much freedom it was a little
bit disappointing to be like the only
unlikable character in a movie full of
incredibly likeable people but it was
kind of a lot like what it looked like
you know sort of like bunch of young
people having fun mostly working nights
sort of running around feel like we were
sort of making it up as we went along
and as I look back I'm amazed that Rick
was so comfortable with that given like
how much you need to schedule movies and
plan them out and know where you're
gonna shoot but he was really fluid and
he he created a great creative
environment and
definitely the movie where I got the
sense that like this is something you
know it's kind of was demystified like I
could do this you know what I mean maybe
we could make our own movie and he was
very inspiring in that regard
chasing Amy Alissa there isn't another
soul on this planet who has ever made me
half the person I am when I'm with you
and I would risk this friendship for the
chance to take it to the next plateau
because it is there between you and me
you can't deny that that was the first
time that I was like got to play a full
sort of developed leading role and also
got to play kind of a range of emotions
and express myself emotionally and had
this speech about being in love with her
and it was really an interesting
experience because we had so little time
that we had to kind of rehearse like a
play so we rehearsed the whole thing all
the way through a bunch of times so we
just knew the thing back to front and
when we shot it went by really fast you
know what I mean and we shot on 16 and I
don't even remember 20 days or something
like that and I guess I kind of thought
maybe there would be that much rehearsal
on most movies you know I didn't realize
that was a totally unique experience I
slept on Kenneth's couch we all sort of
bunked together and you know we all were
our own clothes and it was definitely
that sort of indie era feel you know and
and he had made Klerk so he was already
kind of famous in the indie world you
know and Rick had already made slacker
when I worked with him so both those
guys I kind of looked up to and admired
as sort of DIY filmmaker models what did
you say you're chasing Amy what do you
look so shocked for man that bastard
does this all time he thinks just
because you don't say anything it'll
have some huge impact and he does open
his focus Chris won't you shut up Kevin
was a big inspiration to me both like
cuz he was able to do all this stuff and
he also was very specific about his
writing he was very text oriented you
know it was not like he was the opposite
of Rick in a sense of like there's no
improv no changing anything he
the writing to be exactly as he kind of
laid it out and not only that but in in
some cases he had like the inflection in
mind that he wanted you to use and I
didn't know any better I didn't know
that you were supposed to give actors
line reading so I was just like okay
I'll say it like that we ended up just
becoming friends and I think it did end
up doing like six movies with them or
something like that and and you know
he's my friend today and I really loved
him and he had he really wore his heart
on a sleeve you know what I mean he was
a caring and thoughtful and empathetic
and it was really like made a big
impression on me that this was a guy who
was making films when I thought you had
to be much older and much more
experienced and much more I don't know
what you know have more gray hair or
something I thought well you know if
Kevin can do it again like that was
right around the time when we were
working on start trying to get Google
hunting made and he was he was a big
inspiration and he helped us with that
and so that was a big part of that
Goodwill Hunting
[Music]
most of the writing for Good Will
Hunting was done improv style we knew we
wanted to do the sort of Reservoir Dogs
slacker clerks version of a movie and
the way you did that was to do it
inexpensively and so we deliberately
wrote a movie that was mostly people
talking in rooms and we wrote a part for
you know what we knew would be the
person that would get the movie financed
because we knew that wasn't us and so we
tried to write some monologues that
would appeal to somebody famous we
didn't even know anybody famous at the
time so it was all sort of guesswork and
mostly it was done because we had
nothing else to do
you know we lived together we were going
ons and a lot of days would go by when
we just were hanging out so we would
talk about it and you know it evolved
quite a bit and changed quite a bit but
some of it is like still those early
improv that we did and we would tape
record and then we go over the tape and
pick out the good parts like the week
after I'm 21 yeah if I can sit in a room
and do long division for the next 50
years
probably make some nice Bank though it
was odd that we even thought that we hit
that we could do this you know what I
mean that it was something that was
possible or that would ever happen I
think we were young enough to be just
sort of an inexperienced enough to just
sort of think maybe it'll work you know
instead of realizing how stacked against
us the the odds were it was definitely
like you know some of those early indie
movie experiences that made me feel like
maybe with the right luck this could
happen and it did mostly due to our
agent Patrick Weitzel who kind of made
people believe in it and got people to
script and that was the the biggest
hurdle that movie had to get over it was
kind of you know to get in the hands of
somebody who actually could make a movie
and he was a young agent at the time
he's still our agent and kind of made
his bones on selling global hunting him
I guess we all sorta did Gus definitely
lent a maturity to the movie it was a
little bit adolescent a little bit naive
you know in its original sort of form
and because Gus was much older than us
and much more mature and more
sophisticated and kind of had a better
sense of when we were pushing too far
you know for sentiment or reaching for
something he definitely made them view
real because it only occurs when you
love something more than you love
yourself
I don't you ever dared to love anybody
that much Robin was just like the
biggest star in the world you know we
just couldn't believe that we were
working with Robin Williams it was like
the fact that he was doing it the fact
that we would get to hang out with him
and like ride in the van with him and
listen to him and like tell jokes
we went up in Washington do stand-up
once it was like you know the beginning
of a very sort of dreamlike fantasy
sequence or something you know where I
was doing all these things all these
things were happening in my life that I
thought I wanted to do but never
actually really believed would quite
come true you know and yet there we were
with Robin Williams and I think you know
he was just coming off like this great
run of movies you know awakenings and
good morning Vietnam and he was like
such a big star and I hadn't even been
around somebody who was famous before
and we would walk down the street and
like people in Boston beg more from walk
I think wow all those movies and that's
what you
or Mork from work huh it was a fantasy
he only worked for three weeks and it
was like I remember every single day
every bit of dailies every bit of
dialogue it was literally a dream come
true
Armageddon doing Armageddon was so alien
to me you know I mean it was like you
know I had done chasing Amy so recently
and we did that for $250,000 and I
remember thinking like we could make 400
chasing Amy's for what we're making this
movie for brave souls traveling into the
heaven it was a really cool experience
because it was with all these actors are
really respected like Billy Bob Thornton
and Steve Buscemi and Owen Wilson and
there were all these cool people that
were doing it and live who was so great
and Bruce was such a like iconic figure
such a nice guy and he was so generous
and kind and fun and he was kind of the
leader of the gang you know and Michael
had a totally different attitude about
filmmaking from anyone I've ever met
before
it was so visual and he obviously has a
very distinctive iconic kind of style
that is like a Michael Bay movie that's
you can recognize
I learned a ton about what filmmaking
was like on a big scale and you know was
a hundred and twenty day is there
something and you know I just never seen
anything that massive plus we had
cooperation from NASA and there we were
on the Space Shuttle it was like it was
an incredible experience
[Music]
I really learned a lot about the sort of
professionalism and you know from the
crew was really excellent they were
really talented it was a lot of fun I
wasn't expecting that we were making an
art movie I mean I knew enough to know
like this isn't really an Oscar type
movie this is a you know a fun movie
where like for some reason it's easier
to send like to teach oil drillers to be
astronauts than it would be to teach
astronauts to drill a hole in the ground
I have some great memories from that
movie it was a lot of fun
Pearl Harbor the prep for the movie was
some of the most intensely interesting
and powerful stuff I ever did after two
years of training you believe that a
$45,000 airplane is there for your
amusement I was doing it to try to
inspire the men sir
and the way that you've inspired me I
believe the French even have a word for
that when the men get together to honor
their leaders they call it an homage sir
oh what a no Maj said it's [ __ ]
McAuley i took flying lessons
so I basically learned how to fly and
that was really interesting and fun and
you know flying like a little marchetti
aerobatic airplane not a Santa Monica
Airport and I had been kind of afraid to
fly up to that point and it really helps
my fear of flying to realize the sort of
physics behind flight and how it worked
let's drop it on and give birth
I don't know how they got permission to
do this but they put us in a boot camp
in the actual US Army so we did this it
was Fort Lightning where was the name of
it and it was this pre ranger training
course that basically you did if you
before you went to Ranger school to sort
of prepare you for the rigors of that
and they somehow got us all in it and it
was horrible it was that incredibly
agonizing painful miserable experience
and I would have definitely quit like
the first day if I just wouldn't have
been just too embarrassed like to have
it get out that I quit the training you
know and they yelled at us and they call
us by our character names and like the
guys were really scary and it was
exhausting physically and to this day
it's the hardest thing I've ever done it
was really personally satisfying to get
through it and to like after it was over
have the drill sergeants like treat me
like a normal human being and sleep in a
nice bed I just appreciated everything
so much more it's hard to think about
that movie without like thinking about
how like slammed we got for it you know
because I really thought we were gonna
do something kind of different and ended
up sort of being Armageddon in World War
two but it wasn't as bad as it was like
made out to be it also wasn't a bomb
people always say oh Pearl Harbor bombed
we don't have a billion dollars turns
out that's the way it goes sometimes you
win sometimes you lose sometimes you
kind of win but they say you lost your
first time I believe directing yourself
was that I wasn't confident enough to
direct myself with the first movie and I
really wanted to focus on directing and
I really wanted people to see how
talented I know my brother was so there
was definitely an added level of
pressure with the town in the sense that
I was going to be in it as well and I
was really self-conscious about how many
takes I did on myself and one of the
pieces of advice I got early on from an
actor director was like make sure you
get enough coverage on yourself because
the tendency is to sort of like you know
do a bunch of takes with you too much
takes with you do which takes you and
then just do like one quick take on
yourself and beg okay we can
and you just end up sort of screwing
yourself so I remember like purposely
saying ahead of time I'm gonna do extra
takes on myself don't don't think it's
you know it's because someone told me to
do it it's not because I'm narcissistic
and being on set I was used to being on
camera actually that wasn't the
stressful part the stressful part was
the directing and the directing of other
actors and the directing of action and
the car chase and that was the stuff
that I really had no experience with
you know oftentimes felt like I was you
know doing on the fly and making up as
we went along and that was what I was
really scared wasn't gonna work that I
would be revealed that as a bad director
because you know the car chase wasn't
tense enough for the shootouts weren't
realistic feeling or whatever
he large over that movie you know it was
such an iconic movie about bank robbery
and you know it did had such great
acting in it and it felt like I
definitely did you know tip the hat to
the movie because we have a clip of the
movie in the movie but I definitely
remember being intimidated by the fact
that he had been so good and thinking
that we would be compared to that and
and being really nervous about the
technical aspects of that movie the
truth is that movie was really made in
the research of it madam of Y Cummins
Amud Korea I have ten to twenty fifty
two-years-old picks up every Wednesday
and Friday at exactly eight twelve makes
one hundred and ten dollars a day
carries a signal I spent a lot of time
with guys at the FBI I went to a bunch
of prisons and talked to a bunch of guys
who had robbed armed trucks and got a
lot of really interesting stories from
that spent a lot of time in in
Charlestown really it was more of a
Charlestown of the late 80s and then it
reflected the reality of Charlestown at
that time but there was a time when it
was really you know the sort of bank
robbery capital of the world Argo Argo
[Music]
was written by a guy named Chris Terrio
produced by smoke house and and made it
Warner Brothers and it got submitted to
me you know as like because I had done
the town with Warner Brothers and they
said you know mid-levels what a drama
seemed to be my where I kind of fit in
and you know they had this script and
and as soon as I read it I just thought
like this is I have to make this movie
Mary who would last three prime
ministers of Canada Trudeau Pearson and
what's your father's name Howard what's
his occupation fishing where were you
born how a fax no discussion but you did
a birth February 21st 1952 good what's
your job on the movie producer associate
producer it was the last movie you
produced high and dry who paid for that
CFD what's your middle name what's your
middle name what's your middle name
shoot him he's an American spot it
touched on all these different parts of
my life that I was interested in you
know obviously there's the Hollywood
aspect but also the Middle Eastern
Studies you know major aspect of my life
and it was a part of the world that I
thought was really fascinating and it
was an event that I that I knew a little
bit about but didn't really know as much
about and I had done some research with
the CIA around the sum of all fears and
so I knew that it was a much more sort
of bureaucratic place than it was like a
sexed up headpiece and rifle you know
like assassin's Den and I thought that
was really interesting and I just
thought Krista's script was so smart and
so unique and I had such great
characters you know I thought like this
is something where I could use a lot of
the actors who I know out there who are
really good who aren't necessarily stars
but who are just fabulous actors I mean
it just seemed obvious to me that that
it was a really brilliantly written
movie and I could only screw it up you
know what I mean and all I had to do I
remember thinking was just like deliver
on each day each moment like really
approach it sort of on a one day at a
time basis because you know otherwise it
was a little scary you know it was like
these two competing tomes you had a
comedy at a thriller you had Hollywood
and you had the Middle East things that
didn't necessarily seem to go together
so I was nervous that it wouldn't sort
of all gel and work I just definitely
approached it as just get this scene
right just get that moment right that
was just a movie where I just got lucky
every step of the way
lucky to get the script got the best
actor scared of getting the locations we
want to be shot at the CIA we shot at
the State Department we had amazing
technical people working on it and an
incredible cast and crew and it was just
like I know that I'm just the I was the
beneficiary of a lot of talented people
and a lot of good luck
Oh Superman bestest League I don't think
I even realized how iconic the character
was until I took the job and like that
was a big story and it happened at the
time when the internet was expanding
into the movie business and in kind of a
different way you know what I mean and
like the fan sites and the relationship
with the fans and the studios and the
comic book creators and stuff was
changing and evolving Zach told me he
wants to basically do the tone of the
The Dark Knight you know Frank Miller
series where he's older and he's kind of
broken down and more vulnerable and I
thought that was a really interesting
approach to Batman
if the spirit of that as a guy who's
vulnerable as a guy who's aches when he
gets up in the morning as a guy who like
feels a lot of psychological sort of
torment I thought was a really
interesting approach to to planting a
hero and that was that was how you know
what we want to do and you know III
really had a better time on Batman vs
Superman which I really enjoyed doing
and Justice League was unfortunately
like you know touched by you know some
personal tragedy and of you know death
and Zach's family and it's just like I
say sometimes things sort of work in
jail and sometimes they just you know
you seem to be just having one problem
after another you know I really loved
Batman vs Superman and Chris wrote on it
and and I really loved Zach and I loved
putting on the costume and the idea of
doing the digital alteration to the
voice was really interesting to me and I
had a good time I love Detroit it was a
really fun say - a really cool place you
know my kids came out and visited me and
saw me in the bath suit and they let me
borrow the suit for my son's birthday
and so that was a lot of fun and I sort
of had my fill of that they said we do
you want to direct and star in like a
solo Batman movie I found that I had
kind of at just some point lost my
enthusiasm or passion for it you know I
was like this should really be made by
somebody for whom it's their wildest
dream you know come true and for me it
was it become like something different
and it was clear to me that it was time
to move on but I do have some really
fond memories particularly of Batman vs
Superman and how exciting that was and
how energizing it was and and how much
fun we had the way back the way back was
a really interesting movie for me
because some of it was I could really
identify with it was like you know I'm a
recovering alcoholic this guy's an
alcoholic and I understood a little bit
of that and I kind of could understand
what he was going through and so it was
like interesting to have such a an
intimate relationship on some level with
an emotional issue of the character had
and also you know
main source of pain obviously in his
life was the death of his son you know
which I I couldn't even imagine what
that would be like so it was kind of on
the one hand something I was really
comfortable with and on the other hand
it was I had to totally sort of use my
imagination for what it would be like to
feel that much pain and to suffer that
much and to kind of carry that much
resentment you know against sort of the
world and also you know I'd never been a
coach before so I had to develop this
relationship with the guys playing the
players who are amazing fantastic guys
and that one just turned out to be a
little bit like Argo like I just felt
like everything was sort of working well
and the cast was great and you know we
got lucky with a bunch of stuff and I
felt really emotionally connected and in
tune with you know where I needed to be
character wise it was really just fun
every day and that's a weird thing to
say about a movie that's got a lot of
dark emotion in it but ultimately it was
an inspirational movie you know and it's
a kind of a movie about overcoming
adversity and had a message of hope that
really resonated with me and it really
still does now and it's probably the
performance I'm the most proud of